the race continues for a coronavirus
vaccine
still the highest hopes of treating
infections are medicines that already
exist
approved for other diseases or in
development
it's called repurposing
you want to go with the things that you
do know that work such as
rem desevere appears to be being not
totally effective but
is helpful so you'd want to go with
drugs like that
maybe plasma maybe the experimental
antibodies that are available
it's important to know at what stage a
treatment is most effective
medicines helpful early on when the
infection is mild or there are no
breathing problems
could be ineffective or harmful to a
patient with severe pneumonia
[Music]
big pharma firms continue to scour their
portfolios for possible solutions
the world has never faced a pandemic of
these proportions
in a moment i'll talk to an expert from
the european medicines agency
first a look at some of the drugs that
are being repurposed
anti-viral medicines were originally
developed for hiv
ebola hepatitis c influenza and two
other coronal viruses sars and mares
they're designed to stop the disease
from reproducing
or entering lung cells
anti-inflammatories are used to treat
rheumatoid arthritis or inflammatory
intestinal diseases
they're supposed to limit the body's
defenses and severe lung infestations
to avoid further inflammation which
would cause more damage than the disease
medicines for lung complications are
designed to treat idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis
they help supply the patient's lungs
with sufficient oxygen
and help the lungs repair themselves
cardiovascular medicines were developed
to treat blood clots
or heart disease they're now being used
to prevent complications from covid19
marco cavaleri is head of biological
health threats
and vaccine strategy at the european
medicines agency
he's a pharmacologist who spent several
years in r d mainly
antibacterials and antifungals in
preclinical and clinical development
so marco where are we at in treating
corona with repurposed medication
yeah we're seeing some uh important
advancement in particular i think the
use of there's a metazone
for treatment of hospitalized patients
we cover 19
and with important results from the
recovery study showing that a benefit to
immortality
using this amazon is an important
advancement and will be used
and also the antiviral rendezvous one of
the first one to be
tested in clinical trials for the
treatment of carbon 19 and showed that
the ability of reducing
the time to recovery so the time to
discharge from the hospital of patients
with the hospitalized
coffee 19 and and therefore these are so
far
the most significant advancement that we
are reaching terms of treatment
this disease i went through the various
treatments before what are the most
effective of these treatments
yeah yeah there's a metazone indeed has
been
giving us the most impressive results so
far and we
really hope to see other intervention
that will be
as effective as this one and really the
combination of different modalities
of treatment would be very important to
be investigating the future
we are posing hope in the new monoclonal
antibodies with
neutralizing activity so really acting
as antivirals
and probably the combination of
antivirals with
immunomodulators might be the most
interesting pathway to follow in the
future
it took a long time to find the right
mix to treat
hiv are we going to have to wait that
long
for covet
we hope not of course sierra everything
is much more compressed in time
and unfortunately there are still a lot
of patients out
with severe cavity 19 and being
hospitalized and we are seen
regretfully in europe a new wave of
of cases including severe cases so we
really hope that
clinical trials that are running at the
moment and there are several efforts
we'll be able to deliver
in a much faster way what we need to
know about what could be the best
intervention here and how to combine the
different
agents of course it's very important and
one of the lesson learned that we need
large randomized clinical trials and the
small fragmented clinical research that
we've seen in the beginning but also in
europe
is not really helpful because we need
large studies to tell us exactly what is
working and in which patients
but instead of repurposing all these
different drugs developed to treat
different diseases what
what about new therapies
yeah in terms of antivirus indeed the
new wave of products
are brand new and they cover both small
molecules
similar to rendezvous or indeed these
antibodies that have that the potential
to neutralize the virus
and being very effective and indeed we
think this with other emerging viruses
like ebola
how they can be really impactful in
terms of reducing the burden of disease
so we are really hoping that all these
new medicines will provide
really new opportunities and really be
helpful and impactful in treating these
patients as you said the
new drugs could reduce the burden the
need for hospitalizations
i guess what we do need is a drug that
works at all stages though
absolutely in fact we are really
supporting the efforts by many
developers
to study different drugs at different
stages of the carving19 disease
starting really from the prophylaxis and
post-exposure prophylaxis going to
treatment of mild disease
in the outpatient and then of course a
treatment of severe carbon 19 in
patients that are hospitalized
and maybe we will need a combination of
different drugs depending on the
different time point on how the disease
is evolving
you're encouraging new therapies but why
isn't more being spent
on that potential vaccines have received
about six times more funding
than for therapies and we don't even
know if we'll get a vaccine
uh i guess for what i can say is that it
is believed that the vaccine could have
at the end of the day a bigger
impact on the course of the pandemic and
also in trying to contain the spread of
the virus and this is what we have been
learning for a number of
viral diseases over years and decades
but of course
you're absolutely right that probably we
need not to forget that also
therapeutics are extremely important and
the effort should be put
also in that area to make sure that we
have a good portfolio
or treatment options that cover
different pharmacological
activities in order to make to make sure
that we can treat as soon as possible
and in an efficient way
patients with different stages of the
disease
you heard it from the eu's top
strategist marco cavaleri thank you very
much for your time
thank you bergenheim is germany's second
biggest pharmaceuticals company with
close to six and a half thousand staff
they're busy working on various drugs
including a special covert 19 therapy
these antibodies may be invisible to the
human eye
but they could play a vital role in
neutralizing the coronavirus
scientists in the laboratories in bieber
say they are developing new treatments
as
fast as they can
we are generating antibodies they bind
with a virus
and prevent it from infecting other
cells and the human body
the copper infected so these antibodies
are designed to catch the virus
after it has entered the body yet before
it can do any damage
this site in upper swabia is berlingen
engelheim's largest research and
development center
the head of the german division says the
prospects for bieber
are good we're sincere
we are in the middle of the process of
building up our team in bieber
our workforce and we expect a slight
increase in personnel over the next few
years
another approach to fighting the
coronavirus is the in-house molecular
library
the so-called treasure troves
these shelves contain over a million
different chemical substances
the accumulated knowledge of the
pharmaceutical giant
researchers are investigating whether
these substances are suitable
for treating some of the effects of
covid19
scientists at berger have joined 36
other pharmaceutical companies and
research institutes around the world
to form a consortium to fight the
coronavirus
if we can work together we can pool the
best information from each contributor
and that is precisely the goal of the
consortium
to bring together all the experts and
move forward quickly
but it could take years before an
anti-coronavirus drug is approved
the scientists at berliner ingleheim say
it's too early to speculate about a
possible release date
time to look at the viewer questions
that have been coming in on our youtube
channel
here's derek williams
is covet 19 now endemic
when i read this question i thought okay
it's time to talk about the elephant in
the room the fact
that despite all of our fondest hopes
this virus is not going to fizzle out
and go away um first let's define
endemic the way we're using the word
here is in its epidemiological sense
which describes
when an infection is more or less
constantly present in the background
within a specific population
and geographic region but it also
implies that it's in a kind of steady
state
which covet 19 is not at the moment it's
still spreading
fast and furiously in many places all
over the planet
one of two things could happen next when
enough people build up immunity to it
through infection or vaccination covet
19 could become
an endemic disease or it could
just apparently burn itself out and
disappear like sars did
but not that's not going to happen in
other words
at this point if we could say that the
disease was endemic
we'd actually be farther along the road
towards returning to life as usual
than we are it would mean covet 19 was
no longer out of control but was
a disease we had tools to cope with
we'll develop those tools eventually
just like we did with aids and influenza
in fact probably a lot faster but but
wiping the virus out entirely at this
point would take a
massive planet-wide strategy like the
one that wiped out smallpox
and has nearly banished polio but
projects like that take high levels of
cooperation between nations
and and they take time so covet 19 is
going to be with us for the foreseeable
future
but to some extent at least for how long
will depend on us
you